la pêche au crabe des neiges est
abondante cette saison au quai de
chibagan les bateaux reviennent avec des
cales pleines de ce précieux crustacés
dans celui-ci il y en a pour 27000 kilos
un peu plus loin l'équipage du RML
termine tout juste son débarquement il
repartira dès ce soir
[Musique]
et rapidement le crabe prend la
direction des usines de transformation
les camions se remplissent à vue d'oeil
mais il y a un problème le marché n'est
pas si gourmand du moins pas encore et
le prix offert aux pêcheurs est très bas
2 dollars 25 à livres soit 5 dollars le
kilo c'est le même prix sur tous les
quais de l'Atlantique et du Québec c'est
pas beaucoup on va dire ça à peine pour
couvrir les dépenses qu'on fait
qu'importe les bateaux continuent leur
pêche effrénées avant l'arrivée des
baleines noires dans les prochaines
semaines quand ils reviennent dans la
région au printemps des zones de pêche
doivent fermer
et pendant ce temps les usines débordent
des crabes des travailleurs font jusqu’à
12 heures par jour 7 jours sur 7 pour
tout transformer comme ici chez les
Grassis foods à Tracadie c'est un début
de saison intense sans qu'on sache
encore si tout le crabe va s'écouler le
principal marché est celui des
États-Unis il était mal en point en 2022
on a perdu comme industrie des provinces
atlantiques et du Québec des centaines
de millions de dollars parce que le
marché a craché il s'est effondré l'an
dernier victime des effets de la
pandémie et de l'inflation les
consommateurs ont boudé le crabe quand
les prix ont atteint des sommets il a
coûté jusqu'à 65 dollars le kilo en
poissonnerie à Montaigne du jamais vu
conséquence il est resté beaucoup de
crabes non vendus dans les congélateurs
jusqu'à ce printemps nous les acheteurs
américains nous dit oui on est prêt mais
un prix
très très abord l'objectif digitériaux
et de rester la tête hors de l'eau cette
saison c'est très important de ne pas
perdre d'argent parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de transformateurs quand même qui a
beaucoup de difficultés financières à
cause d'un embrassé et qui ne pourra pas
se permettre de connaître une autre
année de déficit
et c'est pourquoi les transformateurs
n'offrent pas plus aux pêcheurs 2023 est
une année de rétablissement pour
l'industrie les crabiers ses résines
dans l'espoir de recevoir quelques
dollars de plus le kilo l'an prochain il
n'y a qu'atterneux vous les pêcheurs
refusent toujours de sortir en mer à ce
prix et d'ici là la pêche continue
ailleurs
à la fin mais en protéger
c'est une saison difficile pour
l'industrie mais le consommateur lui
s'en sort très bien le crabe lui coûte
beaucoup moins cher un répit sur son
portefeuille jusqu'au retour en force de
l'industrie en 2024 si tout va comme
prévu ici Michel Bridoux Radio-Canada